it brought home to people how few big
companies are actually in this market
and that in turn brought home the fact
that the political agenda that companies
are often indulging in has become so
Universal because there are so many
Industries we have this amount of
concentrated commercial power that they
can change the culture so easily with
one ad campaign now I don't know if they
succeeded in this one there's a backlash
but from their perspective it might
actually be a successful marketing
campaign because they've raised brand
awareness to new heights people are
talking about their beer I don't think
so maybe maybe but if unless they come
out with a with an apology then it's
just very very negative I mean you've
got Ron DeSantis coming out today I
think it was today and he said I'm not
going to buy their beer anymore why
would I like it's just cascading and
normally these stories they don't last
three weeks